[موسيقى]
اخف موجات البرد برد لحيمر وسمي بهذا نسبه
الى نجم قلب العقرب الاحمر وهو برد الوسم
اي انه يحصل في موسم الوسم واشد مواجهات
البرد برد لزيري وسمي بهذا لان الاساتذه
من شدته ويحصل في النصف الاخير من
المربعانيه
اي انه يتاتى في النصف الاول من
المربعانيه وسمي جويريه بهذا لانه يجرد
الاوراق عن غصونها وجويد هذا هو اللي يفتح
باب الشتاء وتبدا تهب علينا الموجات
الشتويه بين ان واخر على فترات متقاربه
وجويريه يؤثر على الشجر ولزيق يؤثر على
البشر خبري بهم يا عيد هبت جويريه واليوم
انا يا عيد بقران هادي يا عيد
عيد ورا عيد عيد الضحايا وعيد صوم
عبادي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وطوال فتره الشتاء الفعلي ديسمبر ويناير
وفبراير يبدا المرتفع سيبيري يؤثر بشكل
مباشر على روسيا وشرق اوروبا وشمال العراق
وشمال تركيا وبلاد الشام ويبني الثلوج
عليهم وتتعسر الحياه ويؤثر بشكل غير مباشر
على بردانه الخليج برياحي شماليه بارده
بين ان واخر غدرا ولينا عنه ما يدفي اللبس
برد الشمال وناطحين محبه
شرباني هنا كم الدبس تنام يا دراع يا شيخط
ما يشبه
[موسيقى]